oh I just love the smell of a good
royalty deal in the morning welcome to
another episode of ask mr. wonderful and
I mean ask me anything you ask the
questions and I give you the answers
bring them on
hey mr. wonderful I had a quick question
for you what prompted you to have this
unabashed honesty on shows like Shark
Tank or were you always just like that
thanks hey or a great question you know
here's the way I look at it business is
really binary black and white either you
make money or you lose money I would
rather just tell the truth all the time
my mother taught me something once if
you always tell the truth you never have
to remember what you said that's why I'm
the same way all the time
I just tell the truth and by the way I'm
the only shark that does everybody else
is trying to pander to their feelings I
don't care about their feelings I care
about their money and you know if they
have a bad idea
they didn't get bit in the hiney
eventually anyways so I'd rather just
tell them right out of the gate tell
them the truth that's my strategy
hello mr. wonderful I am a new Sales
Manager and I want to know what are the
top three characteristics you look for
when hiring top sales talent Mary
fantastic question about top sales
talent let me tell you how it works I've
been doing this my whole life the
salespeople that really succeed are able
to set targets on a monthly or quarterly
basis and make them make them in other
words don't set targets you can't
achieve if you tell me you're gonna get
a hundred thousand in sales in a week or
a month or whatever it is get a hundred
thousand in sales
know exactly your territory know what
your potential is and don't overestimate
the sales people that really advance are
the most coveted are those that have
stability to their forecasts that's what
I'm talking about
I love salespeople men and women that
know what they can achieve and
consistently deliver on those numbers
sounds like you might be one of them
Mary I was gonna ask something political
I decided not to so I'm going to keep it
fun
does mr. wonderful have a bucket list
Wes I wish you'd asked the political
questions I love politics I'm a
political policy wonk I'm just totally
into that but do I have a bucket list
yes it's very simple I look at
tomorrow's activities and anything I
don't want to do I just don't do I want
to spend my time doing things that
interest me I want to pursue things that
are intriguing very often I haven't done
before and work with people I want to
work with
that's what financial freedom is all
about I don't have to answer the phone I
do because I want to and I'd like you to
achieve the same thing I want that for
everybody it's not about the great of
money it's the freedom it lets you have
to do the things that really matter to
you all right Kevin so here's the
question for the average working
individual so having a job working for
somebody else being very disciplined
about both saving and investing which
option would you recommend would you
recommend investing in a Roth IRA where
you can take advantage of those tax
benefits you don't quite have access to
it but you and you don't have exact
control over your money but you know
that it's there you know that it's
growing with a good company with good
mutual funds or ETFs or whatever they
use or would you recommend investing
with an individual brokerage account and
building a dividend paying portfolio
like you talked about in most of your
interviews and videos online where you
talk about diversification and not
invest certain percent more in each
sector each company that way you have
the dividends that you're building and
you also have more control over what
happens with your money thanks Kevin it
was good teeing in Milwaukee and I hope
to hear a response from your question
hey James look that's a great question I
always prefer the taxed Advantage
strategy that you talked about in the
Roth IRA I will tell you why you don't
want to touch that money anyways and
frankly once you put it into a
diversified ETF you're getting the
market diversification you need stock
picking is very hard but I love anything
that can recruit tax-free is really
great and it forces you to leave alone
let it grow so which one should be
putting in ten percent of your salary
into that every year so definitely the
Roth IRA with a nice diverse
conservative ETF of at least 20 stocks
and that's the way to go
I love dividends but I love leme even
better when they're taxed advantaged
this one comes from Zach I'm mr.
wonderful my question to you is on shark
tank
I hear the sharks say a lot of times
that people have products and not a
company I'm out but in other cases I see
sharks actually buying businesses that
are just products and not companies so
is this just a way to say I don't see me
making money with your product and if
the product is a good idea would you
invest because you see a vision on how
to build a company around that product
or it's just a solid product that you
see nothing but dollar signs thanks for
your consideration hey Zach that's a
great question you know it's true
sometimes people have a great product
but not a company not a business a
single product company is very
challenging because it's very very risky
if anything happens that product or it
gets knocked off or it's no longer
competitive there's no other source of
revenue so what I like to do if it's a
single product is call it what it is not
a business it's a product so why not do
a royalty deal in other words say look I
don't need to own the product I need to
own the revenue stream so give me 7% of
sales or whatever and I'll get behind
the thing and blow it up I was the first
to bring the royalty deal into the shark
tank ecosphere now every Sharks copying
me
they have no creativity those guys so
they're always doing my structures well
what do you expect I should invoice them
for what they're learning from me
they're all grasshoppers
hello mr. O'Leary this is Sundeep from
Toronto thank you for giving me this
opportunity to ask you a question
I am a registered nurse working at a
hospital and we are always short-staffed
I am looking to start my own staffing
agency but don't know how to start can
you guide me on how to get a contract
and how to beat my competition should I
offer a better price for the staff I
send thank you so much
Sundeep sounds like you want to be an
entrepreneur it's a great question you
know the key is you're coming from the
industry you understand and yes staffing
is a big issue your first task is to
find five people
qualified that you can actually be a
staffing agency with so you can get them
contracts with hospitals or care
providers and you have to add at least a
fifteen to twenty percent margin to them
but the fact that they don't have to be
full-time employees may be a big
advantage for you the thing is if you
want to do this you got to try
entrepreneurship is not a destination
it's a journey it's full of risk and
hardship and lots of challenges but if
it's burning inside of you you got to do
it and I think it's a great area there's
a never-ending demand for good health
care professionals so it's not like the
market isn't there it's how talented you
are in actually hurting sheep which is
really what the talent business is about
if you're an agency you got to find
qualified people that show up on time
our good workers pay them well pay them
on time and your job is to find them
contracts whether they be short term or
long term and if you keep the client and
the actual worker happy the people that
are coming into your agency it'll be a
very good business I know people that do
this even for hostesses in arenas
they've built a big business by just
getting great hostesses that show up on
time and all those boxes that people
want that's a fantastic business - same
idea now you understand what I'm talking
about good luck to you I own a small
manufacturing shop in South Florida I'm
not ignoring operations but I want to
get more business into my company more
local business how much more should I
focus on marketing versus operations and
I don't want to get overloaded with too
much work and disappoint customers my
question is how to balance the two and
still be able to manage you be Thomas
the age-old question about capacity and
your ability to service your customers
there's no question you want to service
customers that have a very high quality
of customer service that's how you keep
them coming back for more but you also
want to be running at 90-95 capacity so
it sounds like you need to add a little
bit of marketing but not too much that
balance is something you have to do on a
quarterly basis you have to kind of
forecast what's coming down the pike
every 90 days and build a little more
span into marketing when it softens up I
like to be running a
at 90% capacity minimum that's when
you're their most profitable you've got
a little bit of wiggle room for helping
out a customer wants a little bit more
but you've also used the majority of
your productivity by being at almost
full capacity it's what they call work
it's the talent of the balance that
really matters
sounds like you should do a little more
of it and focus a little harder on that
90-day cycle good luck to you
[Music]